Una popular banda de blues regresó recientemente
de una exitosa gira por 3 ciudades,
donde tocaron para al menos 120 mil personas.
¿Ok?
Aquí hay un dato importante,
al menos para 120 mil personas.
Si tenían una audiencia
de 45 mil en la Ciudad de México
y otras 33 mil en Guadalajara,
¿Cuántas personas asistieron en Acapulco?
Entonces lo que tenemos que plantear,
es primero una desigualdad,
para poder determinar
cuántas personas al menos asistieron en Acapulco.
Entonces digamos que
los que hayan asistido en Acapulco
digamos que eso es "a"
si les sumamos lo que asistieron...
la cantidad de gente que
asistió a la ciudad de México,
más la cantidad de gente que
asistió a Guadalajara
eso debe superar o igualar a 120 mil,
entonces si le sumamos
45 mil que asistieron
al concierto en la Ciudad de México,
y le sumamos otros 33 mil
que asistieron al concierto en Guadalajara,
eso debe ser mayor o igual
que 120 mil
porque al menos fueron 120 mil personas las que los vieron en concierto
entonces,
¿qué es lo que hacemos ahora?
Si queremos saber
¿Cuánta gente asistió
al concierto de Acapulco?
Pues hay que despejarla la "a"
Entonces primero
podemos agrupar esto
y cuánto es 45 mil más 33 mil,
bueno pues estos son más o menos...
no, no son más o menos
son exactamente 78 mil,
que si le sumamos "a"
eso debe ser mayor o igual
que 120 mil,
entonces ¿cómo le hacemos para despejar?
pues restamos de ambos lados, 78 mil
restamos de este lado 78 mil
y restamos también acá 78 mil
del lado izquierdo, estos se cancelan
y simplemente me queda,
que la cantidad de gente que asistió a Acapulco
fue mayor o igual que 120 mil  -78 mil
que bueno,
si si pensamos este...
que le quitamos...
en realidad estamos hablando de...
si... perdón, si le quitamos 80 mil
entonces estamos
diciendo que son
120 mil menos 80 mil son 40 mil,
pero hay que sumarle 2 ¿verdad?
porque son -78 no -80
entonces,  si nos quedaban 40
y le sumamos 2 son 42 mil personas
¡Y ya terminamos¡
Eso es todo,
fueron al menos
42 mil los asistentes.